i feel like we've lost more artists
recently than we've lost
in a very long time it feels like
you know we just lost just lost dolph um
obviously
king von last year i mean we could go on
and on so many people are passing like
is there any anything you learned from
just being a man in this industry and
just being a man in this world like like
dealing with the loss or just dealing
with like
you're 50 right we talk we talk that
[ __ ] always hurts bro yeah like i'm
saying like the problem is you just
don't be surprised but it hurts
and when you know a lot of people
everything that happens affects you
when you love a lot of people you get a
lot of hurt
and i'm a guy that likes to help people
so everyone like that i've tried to help
or people that i've tried to help not
everyone because i help a lot of people
but the people that i've helped that
have gotten killed
it hurts
you know it hurts i have to get therapy
every time
it never doesn't affect me
therapy something that
obviously
is that is that something that you know
i feel like is finally kind of starting
to become
less of a stigma doing it but yeah of
course i made it cool so yeah i do
healing as gangster
you know our culture doesn't usually get
therapy so the study of people doesn't
come from black people it comes from
white people
so when the black person finally does
get therapy he's getting the medicine at
a white person he's not a black person
different kind of trauma
so we need to find people that speak in
our tongue
that can actually help us but it is cool
to have a consulary
you know someone that doesn't have a dog
in a fight that could tell you things
just based on statistics
it's a consultant for your life you know
if you think that's weak trying to make
yourself strong then you're just a
[ __ ] clown to me
walking around bleeding stitching [ __ ]
up and not healing it
just going to continue to bleed you know
it's dumb and the thing about being
uncomfortable for me i don't like being
uncomfortable so i do anything i can not
to be uncomfortable as quickly as
possible so something's bothering me
immediately i'm trying to figure out any
way i can not to be bothered anymore but
people would rather be bothered and not
deal with it i just don't logically get
that